في العصر الرقمي باتت التكنولوجيا سبيلا
لصنع صور معدله وحتى مفبركه اما المشاهدات
المليونيه فتقتضي ان تكون اللقطه لشخص مهم
او ربما لفعل لافت للانتباه فالصوره قد
تصنع ضحكه او تثير تساؤلا وربما تشعل حربا
وفي الاونه الاخيره اجتاحت بعض المشاهد
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هذا هو الرئيس
الروسي
يبدو جاثيا على ركبته يقبل يد نظيره
الصيني
لقت الصوره رواجا بين المستخدمين ليس
لانها حقيقيه بل لانهم متيقنون من انه لم
ولن يفعلها ولكنها قد ترضي المستائين من
افعاله ولو كذبا فبعد التنقيب عنها بسبب
هفوات برسم التفاصيل كاليدين تبين انها
انشات على هانجين فيس وهنا الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب مكبلا بين
ايدي الشرطه حقق امنيته موقع بالاعتقال
والمثل امام المحكمه وكتب له مشاهدات وصلت
لخمسه ملايين لكن يده المفقوده فضحت حقيقه
الصوره المفبركه واذا ما تحدثنا عن تطبيق
تشادمه والاخر حكايه تجمع الرئيس الامريكي
الاسبق باراك اوباما بالمستشاره الالمانيه
السابقه
وعنوانها بيوم على الشاطئ يقول ان حياتهما
بعيدا عن السياسه مليئه بالمتعه اما
الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمير زيلينسكي
والذين شهره واسعه بسبب ظهوره المتكرر فقد
نشرت عنه صوره قيل انه من النازيين الجدد
شائعه لم تلبث طويلا فبعد التمحيص في
مقاطعه بدا انه لصليب فيكتوريا لا لصليب
النازيه المعقوف وشتان ما بينهما
مقاطع لم يستلم منها الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون وزوجته برجت حينما قيل ان
هذه الرقصه جمعتهما صغيرين ولكنها تعود
لبرنامج امريكي راقص قبل سبع سنوات تكثر
الصور وتتعدد الحكايات ووراء كل صوره الاف
الكلمات حقيقيه كانت ام مفبركه فالاولى
تتكلم الواقع اما الثانيه فترسم خيالا
مرجوا